[Musique]
en fait c'est un jeu de cartes qui est
déployé par l'animateur pendant une
heure et demie et au fur et à mesure du
déploiement les participants prennent
conscience des causes et des
conséquences des changements climatiques
et à l'issue de du déroulement du jeu on
constitue une fresque parce que ça
s'étale sur une très grande table et
ensuite on les invite à réfléchir à des
actions qui pourraient mettre en oeuvre
soit leur échelle individuelle soit leur
échec collective
[Musique]
beaucoup de monde
propose de réduire ses déplacements donc
soit en réduisant ces déplacements en
avion soit en prenant davantage des
transports collectifs en réduisant les
faits en réduisant la voiture donc en
faisant plus de covoiturage
d'autres proposent de réduire leur
consommation de bœuf et du coup de plus
se diriger vers une alimentation plus
locale ou en tout cas sans en y mettant
ses consommations de viande de bœuf
[Musique]
on va la déployer dès demain faites avec
les conseils municipaux juniors qu'on
va sensibiliser demain pour la fresque
des enfants en fait le jeu est moins
long l'atelier dure deux heures il y a
moins de cartes
c'est plus ça à leur portée et comme on
a souhaité le déployer d'abord avec
notre conseil municipal junior et
conseil local des collégiens parce que
c'est plus facile pour nous de le
déployer à leur échelle que directement
à l'échelle des écoles on va voir ce que
ça donne et après si on peut on fera ça
à la rentrée une plus grande échelle
[Musique]